hello everyone this is amie here from
audio science review
you all asked for more debunking videos
sorry
here's another one uh it's this whole
category of
usb filters and what are fondly called
the crapper fires i think
that's an industry term these days uh
it makes sense right you take a computer
usb port hooked up to a deck computer's
busy doing a ton of things which it
is and that it surely must generate
noise that then
finds itself into a deck and pollutes
the output of the deck
you could say that's noise it adds
jitter
takes away detail and what have you so
uh
manufacturers know this and uh for last
i don't know
seven or eight years they've been
building uh these filters i think one of
the earliest ones
was this audioquest jitterbug very very
catchy name
very clever marketing you can see i was
a
early adopter buying mine back in 2015
i buy them so you don't have to uh
i'm fascinated that they sell
multi-packs of this
you can buy one or three or five and i
believe they advertise you should use
more than one and that
you not only pass your uh dac output
through this but you also plug it into
the uh
other usb ports you have on your
computer and snuffs the noise out of
them
um assuming they think that they're all
shared ports on the same usb controller
which may be but uh and i've seen people
string a whole bunch of these things and
different brands where they put like
five or six of these things in series
and of course
every time they add one the sound
improves so they add another one had
another one add another one
so uh our challenge is to find out if
these things uh
improve the sound or not and
so let's take into a review that i did
of the jitterbug
it's actually the second time i've
reviewed it and measured it
this what it looks like if you go down
here you'll see that it says it remove
reduces jitter and packeters
resulting distortion that causes flat
and irritating
sound if you get packet errors you will
know it
it'll buzz crackle i mean you basically
have a chunk of
kilobytes of data from your audio is
just taken out
so the waveform will go like this and
then it'll be a
chopped out section it will not result
in any of the things they're talking
about it won't sound flat it just sounds
awful
and in the short lengths that we use usb
cables for
you know typical home views this is
absolutely not a problem once it becomes
a problem this won't fix it anyway
you'll need a repeater or some other
method to extend the length of
usb cable and uh but anyway
the rest of it if it results in
distortion we measure distortion if it
results in noise we measure noise if it
was
results in sierra we measure jitter
that's what we're here for
so um how to test it i took a topping
d50s
uh one neat things about topping neat or
for this case
is that it has a separate nine volt
adapter in there so let me see if i can
find it yeah so
sorry a 9 volt connector but it's really
a usb
plug so they give you a little cable
that goes from this power port to a usb
that powers it and you can either power
it with a you know your own
phone charger what have you then it's
got a data port that you use to actually
communicate with it so we get to plug in
an experiment with the um
jitterbug on on both ports see if it
makes difference on one or the other
because there's a theory as to whether
the data is noisy on usb
or it's the uh data bus that's noisy or
both
so let's go back to our measurements so
here i
plug it in in series with the power port
and measure the
output of the dac remember that's the
only thing we're interested
none of us listen to a usb cable by
sticking in our ears
this usb is carrying digital data we
need to convert that to analog
and all we care about at the end of the
day is what comes out of our dac not
what goes in it what goes in it is
the designer's problem so if we measure
the uh
d50s and take a wide spectrum of of one
kilohertz tone so this is our desirable
tones and all this other stuff is
unwanted but they are very very low
level
and uh we compare it with uh
topping by itself in in red and then
topping
uh with 50s with with jitterbug plugged
into it
and as you can see the two graphs just
land on top of each other there is
absolutely no reduction in noise we had
all this noise it could get rid of we
could had all this distortion
that it could get rid of and it got rid
of none of those
let's connect it on the data bus and see
what that does
and this time i'm zooming into just 20
kilohertz bandwidth
and again stuff just lands on top of
each other no matter how we plug it in
and so clearly no
distortion was taken away you can see
all these little bits of noise in here
surely if it reduce any noise
those little ticks should have at least
gone down but no even measuring down to
minus 150 decibels 160 decibels
it makes no difference and
uh another test i ran which is just
everything's plugged in the way it is
but i don't
turn on a stream of audio to the uh
to the dac so we're just looking at
residual noise that's on the analog
output of the dac
and again we tested with other quests on
you know whether it's on power or
whether it's on data notice that the
background noise is the background noise
there is no difference whatsoever so
what is filtering dilutes this testing
at least so someone may say well
maybe it doesn't work on that deck maybe
it works on another deck so i once one
step
lower at the time uh topping d10 one of
my favorites i think was like 60
deck at the time and surely this is a
noisier less performant deck than the
topping d50s and and see what we get
there
so here we look at our usual dashboard
now instead of just the zoomed in
spectrum
uh remember this cyan ad is noise and
distortion
and there are around one uh 105 or so
depending on
you know which channel you look at 2.109
volts
coming out of it we plug in the
jitterbug
and what do we see uh still 105.
still 2.11 volts no difference in the
spectrum over here in ffd
look up here you see these three pulses
for example
and identical performance i mean it
couldn't be more the same
than it is so it's absolutely absolutely
absolutely not making a difference
um i run the same fft that i ran before
and while the little variation here
that's just happens you know these
things are random
noise being picked up and what have you
but jitterbug
just doesn't do anything if you look
over here it's just all identical the
two curves land on top of each other
but maybe not of the top index benefit
from this list switch brands to ifi
idsd uh dac it's a lower performing dac
yet again
his cyanide is only down to 93 or 94 db
and uh this is with it hooked up direct
we see the distortions
sort of go from highest to lowest here
and
uh we plug in jitterbug what happens
nothing so you know the exact same sign
add is still there
the output voltage is the same all the
same distortions
there's not a sign of anything happening
in here so might say wow
maybe these dags aren't sensitive to
noise on
usb bus if you had such noise then this
would improve it
my classic answer to that is why would
you buy a dac that has such
dependence on noise on usb but i happen
to have one deck
that it that i know for sure from
testing before that is very sensitive to
the
quality of the usb signal it's an
ancient dac from shed the company
called modi ii the company built state
of the art products today
but at the time they had built this modi
ii
they weren't where they are today and if
you look in here you see the sign ad now
you know drops way down to 73. so we're
way down you can see why the noise floor
is quite high in here and we have a
series of distortion spikes in here
and it only puts out 1.6 volts or so
instead of two volts that the other ones
did
so we go ahead and plug in jitterbug
surely it cleans up the noise on this
guy well no
it even though we have much more
elevated noise
we have a dac that's sensitive and the
cyanide didn't change
interestingly enough the output of the
stack dropped 0.01 volts not a whole lot
but it dropped 0.1.01 volts
which tells me that the uh the jitterbug
is
causing enough extra impedance on the
power line
to cause the output of the stack to drop
a little bit so it's actually doing
something wrong
doing some harm in here rather than
doing some good so
no noise been reduced nothing but you
actually lose a little bit of output
that
you don't want to lose jitter test is
very sensitive and if you
for this to hack and you can see when i
run it what an awful display you get now
this is called broadband random uh
jitter
so it widens the skirt as we call it
around our main 12 kilohertz tone this
is the only wanted signal in here
this is all unwanted and again we
connect jitterbug to it
uh it makes no difference and uh
you know actually as i come it actually
gets a hair worse why it gets a hair
worse
who knows but but it certainly doesn't
make it
any better um once again we also just
look at the noise spectrum
and uh you know that's plugged in and
and we go with it without jitterbug
and noticing here that there's just
nothing
nothing nothing nothing is filtered
whatsoever so
objectively we can't find that it
reduces jitter objectively we can't find
that it reduces distortion objectively
we can't figure out
that it's it's reducing jitter either
well we figure out that it's not
reducing jitter either so it's really
nothing really has happened but the
claim is that well
the ears more sensitive we're not
measuring the right things
never mind the company's claims we did
measure
but doesn't sound any different so
i took this modi deck that is most
sensitive to power line
artifacts and hooked it up to this sms
smsl
thx um sp200 which is a state of the art
headphone amplifier based on thx
technology so it's as transparent as you
could possibly get
and i use my sennheiser hd 650 as a
headphone
and then i drove the moti 2 direct
excuse me or through jitterbug and
i played my best reference tracks with
tons of detail and everything and the
nice thing about roon was that it was
able to recover
when i unplug them plug back things in
in about five seconds able to just
continue playing and uh
i heard no difference whatsoever now
realize
there are a lot of people who buy these
things if you look at the reviews in
here there are 761 reviews
four stars on the average so a bunch of
people think they're hearing a
difference
and i've explained the reason for that
before
because essentially when you change
something in your system
you pay more attention and you're
listening more carefully
and then you say wow look at this sounds
better sounds more fluid there's less
noise
but that's all the fidelity that was in
your source to begin with
and when you take it out you're going to
program yourself into thinking
okay this was the reason it was all
improved you plug it in directly all of
a sudden oh yeah without it sounds dull
no it doesn't have a loved one do the
tests that i did
behind your back so you can't tell and
do it 10 times if 8 out of 10 times you
can tell when jitterbug gets plugged in
when it's not plugged in and i guarantee
you that you will not be able to pass
that
test whatsoever you'll be lucky four or
five times you get it right and
if you get it four or five times and
it's basically randomly guessing
so all the obvious improvements that you
heard and if it's that obvious you
should
you should be able to get 10 out of 10
you're not going to get 10 out of 10
or remotely so or these guys would sell
millions of these things
on this thing now sometimes i do tear
downs on these and but these
come kind of glued together so
but luckily i have a samoy dog
that found this jitterbug that i owned
and managed to chew it up and do a tear
down for me
remarkably the unit worked perfectly
um nothing was damaged despite the case
and you can see
some of his white hairs stuck to this
and uh
so we now courtesy of our dog you get to
see what's in it and i think i'll have a
zoomed up picture of it in here
if you look in here all you're seeing
the l means an inductor and c means a
capacitor
so basically this is just a low-pass
filter
that's put in around data and or power
line
and uh that's fun and dandy but there's
a problem with cleaning up the data
lines the usb bus is running pretty high
speed so these pulses are coming
you can't filter that because if you
filter those pulses the pulses get
rounder and they actually
cause problems building well being able
to extract that data correctly
so filtering is not your friend
necessarily now you could filter
frequencies that are way above the what
the digital receiver wants
and in that case a good thing but boy
you're filtering
very very high frequency rf that doesn't
make it into the device anyway
and power line filtering yeah you could
you know that's dc
so the five volt that's on usb bus you
could filter that
but the question for you is this why do
you think somebody designing a dac
that knows full well is going to be
hooked up to a pc that's noisy pc
wouldn't put these three cents worth of
parts inside your deck
think about it what is that designer
that stupid that didn't know
that this is all you had to do put this
little few parts in there and
bam jitter goes down sound is no longer
flat
it's not irritating anymore this is all
it took
a couple of inductors and capacitors
don't you think these
capacitors inductors are really inside
your deck
the deck never runs off of that 5 volt
input that comes in
it takes a 5 volt input it's only
positive but the dac
many times needs both positive and
negative so it regenerates the negative
using a switching power supply usually
well always if it needs it and even the
positive they don't they want they don't
want five volt usually runs at 3.3 volts
or maybe even higher voltage for the
output stage
so the 5 volt is like a raw input that
comes into the dac
the dac that regenerates it into a dc
and then filters that dc
so what it gets is extremely filtered
that's what the good tags that i test i
test them on this noisy
gaming style workstation i have and i've
tested it on
other computers that i've had all high
performance stacks generally the same
noise same distortion as i've shown you
and it absolutely does not make a
difference why because
any designer knows what they're doing
builds a
proper dac knowing that the usb bus
signal is noisy and you got a filter and
if you could use a
charger the dongle that dongle is also
not going to be the cleanest power
so all of this technology is already in
there
why spend 69 on this you could buy a
whole
deck that doesn't have any usb
dependency for 69 bucks
why would you go spend money on
something like this so
just know that there is no magic in it
there's nothing really in here
you're paying for manufacturing of this
thing the patch you're getting packaging
it's shipping it to you
amazon takes their card all your quest
takes they got whoever made the sticks
they cut
so and i don't want to just go after
audio quests i've tested the other ones
um so one other one is this ifi
um does uh micro i usb
3.0 this one's quite expensive uh
is 400 and somebody sent this to me for
testing
and same story i won't bore you although
before i get there
there's something on their website i
think when i look that he says
this is who's it for is this for systems
that are more than fifteen hundred
dollars
it's kind of a snobbish statement that
if your system's too cheap this is not
good for you
but anyway i do have expensive system a
few would sit on it makes no difference
anyway i won't bore you with all the
measurements uh but
here we have much better text to test
with because time's gone by and it's a
much newer review
you can see that i got 118 db synapse of
topping d90
and if i use it with a usb
it makes no difference but it's got a
little switch where you can float the
ground that can be useful
actually um because you can get ground
loops
but when you flip that up where you're
floating the usb bus
you actually generate new error that
didn't exist at 18 kilohertz and
you can see that in here or 16 kilohertz
um so don't go floating the ground
thinking that it always does some good
it you know doesn't necessarily do any
good so
you know these companies i'm sure will
be up in arms seeing this
this write-up and my answer to them is
what i'll put in here
if you think it's any better than this
show me the measurements
or show me a blind listening tips don't
say we've sold 100 000 of these things
it doesn't matter you can sell
anything to anybody uh on this thing um
just make some claims and make people
believe the claims and then go plug it
in and as i explained
it's just human nature when you go buy
something new and plug it in and
you know you're gonna want it to uh
sound better and it will or even if you
don't think it's gonna sound better you
can still fall prey to what i explained
as far as
your mind changing and looking at these
things so
please don't spend your money on these
things um if there's a new one and by
the way i've tested other ones that i'm
not going over if you go to
audiosciencereview.com and
search for these things you'll see that
i've tested others and it's just the
same story repeats over and over again
uh if if there's a new one and you think
their claims are valid
you're in us send it to me i'll run
these tests i'll listen to them
and we'll get that data but for now
based on years of testing these things
and the fact that the whole concept of
what they do is faulty
they absolutely positively do not do
anything useful
they don't do it useful they don't do it
electrically they don't do it by
measurements and they don't do it for
your ear
either so don't fall prey to oh you know
we don't measure the right things
well i've listened and listened properly
and it absolutely makes no difference
okay thanks for stopping by and hope you
enjoyed this debunking review
or article or video and see you in the
next one
bye